baseball is
back and so are the white sox and the
twins game
two of the season and game two of this
three-game series that guaranteed right
field
dallas keiko looking for his first win
in a white sox uniform we're ready to
play baseball
and dallas kykel has to subdue these
mighty twins because their lineup
is promoted donaldson crushed
left-handed pitching last year has done
that throughout his career a 950
lifetime ops off left-handed pitching
was over three
two walks in his twins debut last night
that strike three that was
enough in the neighborhood for a cycle
strikeout and two down in the first
inning
look he had his eye angle looking down
down down and all of a sudden
upstairs a bit pretty much bisected the
plate
and a good way to start the game two up
two down
towards short only one play and polanco
a good jump right here on this ball by
polanco you see him charging at full
speed
almost loses his balance but still able
to recover
this i mean this is this is an athlete
right here nine straight strikes
thrown by dobneck
and they've all been fouled off here we
go again
finally got him and it's just out number
two but
domnach who's about as placid out there
on the mound as you're gonna see he had
a little
fist bump there that was a big victory
his former
arkansas razorback how about that
and now james goes down the line and
right for the very first hit of the ball
game
to the no hitters we are going to give
you up
mccann a base hit
how about opposite way with some slug
deep left center field to the wall it
goes and banging off the wall
here comes tim he's around to score the
sox take the first lead of the ball game
monkatta
sends one flying and it's one nothing
matter now is going to be josh donaldson
donaldson struck out looking
his first time up there it is
moncada garcia nestled into a brayer's
glove
double play that's the pitcher's best
friend right there
that doesn't get any easier than that
roll through the right side sharply hit
flagged down by adrian's a beautiful
play
and a nice play by polanco as well
having to reach for the throw from
adrianza
here's larry garcia to lead off the
fifth
high in the air right center field
kepler a long run that ball carries up
and out of here
oh a moon shot for laurie garcia
leaves in right center and it's two
nothing
wow leory garcia showing some muscle
and gives edward and carnacion an
opportunity to drive a ball
deep left field he drops the bat watch
it go
to ron homer a mammoth welcome to
chicago and here comes the parrot for
the
first time this year this is a bomb
jimenez to bat in the air right field
well struck gonzalez back still drifting
at the wall
it's up and over yellow line and gone
for eloy jimenez and five
nothing you said it
through the right side it's a knock
[Applause]
robert gets over and keeps garver to a
single but first and third with one out
and the best minnesota rally so far
today corners and here comes
ricky renteria well seashell started to
come out it's there to come out but you
have to wait because ricky occasionally
double backs steve no but we
occasionally leaves the starting pitcher
in this time he says nope
i'll take the baseball
to left and deep and gone
the big hit the twins needed he comes
through again twins right back in this
ball game
this guy just continues to amaze me with
his
approach and the way he's able to come
through for the twins tell me if this is
not the most
mundane is there's a fly ball to right
field pretty well hit gonzalez going
back to the wall
and that's up and out and back in again
james mccann goes yard and the sox are
taking advantage
of the home run ball number
four today runners at the corners two
outs meltzer behind mccann 2-0
anything that happens after that you
never know base hit to left field
james mccann a mammoth day in his 2020
debut
and the sox do add on it's 7-3
well the switch hitting garcia batting
right-handed he's had a good day
oh that ball is absolutely rocked to
left field
down the line good
way gone a two-bomb
afternoon for laori garcia
and ten up for the sox this saturday we
are not worthy
never with triple a rochester and this
ball is tagged to right field
angle going back into the shadows down
the line he goes adam against the wall
is there to make the play
oh adam angle in right field makes the
grab
for out number two you put him in there
and immediately he makes a play like
that
twins are down to their final strike
jimmy lambert spears it and creates his
own final out of his major league debut
keep all the baseballs sox win for the
first time
in 2020 and the final score goes 10-3